all right thank you so much for joining
us
for this sixth in the series of the yale
development dialogues economic policy
lessons from history
today we're going to be discussing
sustainable development on an urbanizing
planet
these are virtual panel discussions
hosted by the yale economic
growth center the south asian studies
council and the jackson institute for
global affairs
i'm catherine chaney a journalist
focused on global development and i'll
be your moderator today
i'm joined by panelists sunil amrith
kate brown
edward glaser and rory stewart whom i'll
introduce in just a moment
but first i want to give a bit of
context on why we're talking about this
topic today
so throughout history as many of you
know or perhaps may study
population growth and urbanization have
been presented as a problem
whether it's about putting a strain on
resources or driving the climate crisis
but historical and contemporary examples
show us how cities can in fact
mitigate sprawl reduce carbon emissions
and in fact foster biodiversity and
we'll hear some examples of that
urbanization seems inevitable and as one
of our panelists ed glaser puts it in a
conversation we had
just preparing for this session there's
no pathway out of poverty into
prosperity that does not run through
city streets
urbanization again is is happening so
the question
is what role can cities play in the
search for green solutions to poverty
today our panelists will offer different
perspectives on what elements of
urbanization are and are not conducive
to sustainable development
so i'll go ahead and introduce our
panelists and then we'll hear from each
of them and move into a conversation
and i just want to remind everyone
attending this webinar
to please put your questions into the
chat
into the q a function here in zoom
throughout the conversation
and then i'll know what's coming what's
resonating and work
your questions in throughout the
conversation so keep those coming
to introduce our panelists uh first i'd
like to introduce to emile amrit he's
the renu and anand dawan professor of
history at yale
and current chair of the south asian
studies council his research
focuses focuses on histories of
environment migration and public health
across south and southeast asia
and he uh helped to put together this
topic and this panel for today so thank
you sunil
we'll hear more from him in a moment ed
glaser is a professor of economics at
harvard university
his research focuses on cities economic
growth law and economics
in particular his work is focused on the
determinants of city growth
and the role of cities as centers of
ideas transmission
he has served as director of the tobin
center for state and local government
and director of the rappaport institute
for greater boston
kate brown is a professor of science
technology and society at mit her
research explores where history science
technology and biopolitics converge to
create large-scale disasters and
modernist wastelands
the author of four books most recently
manual for survival at your noble guide
to the future
she's currently exploring the history of
what she calls plant people which we'll
learn more about
who understood long before others that
plants communicate have sensory
capacities and possess the capacity
for memory and intelligence and rory
stewart is a senior fellow at the yale
jackson institute for global affairs
where he focuses on contemporary
politics and crisis and on international
development and intervention in fragile
and conflict-affected states
stewart as many of you know if you've
tuned into these past webinars
previously served as the uk secretary of
state for international development
where he doubled the uk's investment in
international climate and environment
so i'd like to begin with sunil who i
mentioned is one of the co-hosts of the
yell development dialogues and
and really advocated for this topic as
one to take on so
sunil why this topic why now and why is
this something that
benefits from bringing historical
perspectives together with practitioner
perspectives
so if we think about where we've where
we've been so far in this series
we started with a couple of sessions on
the pandemic and the implications of the
pandemic for development
um more recently we've thought about
green pathways out of poverty
and it seemed to me that this um the
question of cities
brings those together in very
interesting ways particularly at this
moment
and i do think we can benefit very much
from the kind of dialogue we've had
between historians practitioners
economists on the question of cities and
sustainability
in the context of development um so
about a year ago when we were about a
month or two into the pandemic
i think we all saw these photographs and
on social media and the news of
wildlife returning to the city um there
were photos of
delhi from where you could see the
himalayas for the first time in 20 years
um and you know on the one hand i think
this was
uh a wake-up call for so many of us who
perhaps
ignored the biodiversity that has always
lived in plain sight in cities that we
inhabit
um but perhaps there was also a sense um
that this was self-indulgent
that you know here we were talking about
wildlife returning to the city when
people were suffering and losing their
jobs
um and in in a way i think it also there
was a
there was a backlash against it as there
always has been
this idea that green urbanism is in some
ways an indulgence
um and i wanted to think about the
history of that in ways that you know
i'm looking forward to hearing from
from kate about that another way in
which i can see this link
is you know we've been told many times
and i think we're all convinced that
one of the root causes of the pandemic
is the shifting
uh wild wild frontier the shifting
frontier between human beings and
animals particularly wildlife again
we've tended to think of that frontier
as being out there
um but that frontier is also right at
the heart of the cities that we inhabit
um that frontier is um in the food
systems that feed our cities that
frontier
is in the ways that we live that
frontier lives in the
the implications of urban density or
different kinds of urban density so i
also wanted to touch on that
um and finally as a historian myself i
have been struck by the
very ambivalent role of cities within
the entire
project of development since the middle
of the 20th century now on the one hand
you know precisely as
i'd put it you know every path to
prosperity runs through the city's
streets and
if you think about development in 1950s
and 60s not just
in the eyes of experts but even if you
think about you know hindi cinema in the
1950s
the story of development is a story of
the leaving the countryside and moving
to the city
on the other hand i think we've seen
second half of the 20th century in
asia and africa a very deep
anti-urbanism
and i think you find this in india and
china this idea that the soul of the
nation lives in the countryside
that the countryside is the place for um
sustenance and provisioning um and and
you know
until the 1980s you can actually see
that india and china to take those two
examples had much lower rates of
urbanization than most economists
predicted or that economic theory would
have predicted and only in the late 20th
century
you know in a sense did the shackles
come off so i'd be very interested in
thinking about
the history of ideas about the role of
cities within development um as well
thank you and that's something i'm
looking forward to hearing from rory on
also you know
what are these conversations looking
like uh in in development circles
um but i want to bring ed into this and
ed you know cities as we
have we've just as we've discussed you
know are often depicted as enemies of
the environment
but your view is it doesn't have to be
that way so can you expand on what it
looks like when it isn't that way
certainly thank you and and thank you
for including this in this conversation
which i've been really looking forward
to you know i want to jump off on
sunil's comment on
the the the thread of anti-urbanism that
often shows up in the developing world
of course gandhi famously said that the
future of india is in its villages not
in its not in its cities and and
um i cannot tell you how many times i've
been in a
uh developing world uh politicians
office and he's asked me great you're an
expert on cities tell me how i stop all
these poor people from coming to my city
and screwing it up
right that is that is frequently the
line that i have gotten
um and i think that that's a terrible
mistake
even not only obviously our cities
places of economic prosperity
but when you look at the urban rural
life satisfaction gap
so the happiness gap that gap is
non-existent in the developing world
right in the developed world but in the
developing world it's huge and the
country actually where you have the
largest life satisfaction gap in the
world
in in our data at least is india that in
fact india has the biggest gap between
urban happiness and
and uh non-urban unhappiness um
now one of the reasons why people state
for being anti-urban is that they
see urbanism as being antithetical to
the environment i sometimes call this
the lorax fallacy after the
dr seuss uh book which depicts city
building running roughshod over a
natural habitat
and i think part of the reason for that
mistake is a tendency to confuse
urbanization with the process of of
wealth accumulation the process of of
economic development
it is absolutely true that as countries
get richer they're going to use more
carbon unless we do a lot against it
right and you know that's somewhat
inevitable but we have to talk about how
minimizing how many how we can minimize
that
by contrast urbanization is really about
densification
the economic definition of the city is
the absence of physical space between
people and firms
and closeness is a way of reducing
carbon emissions
not a way of increasing them right uh
back of the envelope number that i like
and it's about 10 years old now so take
it with a grain of salt but
if the great growing economies of india
and china see their per capita carbon
emissions rise to that scene in the
sprawling united states
global carbon emissions go up by about
uh tenfold if they stop at
the uh level seen in high wealthy but
hyperdense hong kong
global carbon emissions go up by about
25 no it's 125
versus 25 sorry um so it's really a
massive a massive gap in terms of this
another way of seeing this is is if you
compare the
brownest city in china uh in terms of
its household emissions as opposed to
its total industrial emissions
it is one-fifth of the amount of carbon
per capita than the greenest city in the
united states
so there's really a huge amount of of
gap that's there
now why is it the density is relatively
positive for the environment
there really are two main things that we
see both in u.s and chinese data
the first is the size of the dwelling
typically in cities people are occupying
smaller dwellings even holding income
and family size constant
and so those smaller dwellings just mean
a lot less energy involved in heating
and cooling
in china they don't actually cool
typically except for the very wealthiest
households but they do heat
and consequently the the cities of
northern china are much more carbon
intensive than the cities of southern
china
the second reason is of course moving
people around and
this is a big tension in terms of
bringing biodiversity into the city
that in fact the the you know strongest
prediction of how much carbon you emit
in your you know in your everyday life
is how far the distances are between you
and other people between you and your
job between you and and the places that
you want to go
the more biodiversity that you bring in
between people and cities
the more that you're expanding the
distances between between people and the
more that you end up having people to
to drive longer distances and take
longer commutes in different ways
um so for those reasons there's really a
substantial uh
carbon emissions gap between people
living in central new york versus people
living in in suburbs
so i think i'll stop there but the
central point being
there's nothing wrong with density for
carbon emissions in fact it's a it's a
good thing for us to be close to one
another
the challenge is as the world gets rich
and i think we all want the world to get
rich
how we can make sure that the world gets
rich in a way that doesn't involve
massive amounts of energy use that put
the planet in peril
thank you ed and to build on that point
i know kate
brings uh unique insights from her
research and lessons from history so
um you know kate i'd love your take as
ed mentioned
uh closeness and and density can
actually have positive implications for
the environment but how do we
steer it that way uh so what are some
insights you have to share in terms of
uh ensuring that urbanization is not in
conflict with
but perhaps in support of preserving
biodiversity
now well let's look at the past as i'm a
historian
in paris in 1900 5000 parisian farmers
fed 2 million parisians with leftover to
be
shipped to london in washington dc where
i am right now
soil migrants migrated up to dc from the
south where they lost their farms
because the soil was exhausted
and it could no longer produce and they
started farming
their periphery of dc in dc but where
they were allowed to live as
african americans and they um
tax records and housing records have an
amazing fact that among
people in this anacostia region of dc
rates of homeowner occupancy
a significant indicator of financial
stability were some of the highest in
the city 1959 percent
in 1940 versus 33 for white residents
so black residents of anacostia
denied equal access to housing education
public infrastructure
financing and jobs were able to pay down
on their homes when most other white
neighbors were not able to do that
and they managed to do that by growing
their own food
and trading some of it you know locally
look at the soviet union 1990 i was
living in
moscow everybody talked about famine
soviet agriculture had collapsed
same thing happened in cuba but what did
people do
they got on the commuter trains and they
went out to
the peri urban areas had small plots and
they grew their own potatoes
by 1996 91 percent of all potatoes grown
in russia were grown by small plot
gardeners stache gardeners
on 1.5 percent of the arable land in the
country
so we're not talking about that we need
a lot of space
[Music]
what's really sort of amazing is that
people abandon or neglected by their
government
and manage to come up with their own
technological solutions these are not
primitive people the
parisian farmers used the mass of horse
manure that gathered in
the city they used the urban walls to
have
wall orchards they in that way created
their own micro climates
and produced their own soils and they
ended up selling those soils to farmers
outside of the city they had so much so
many great nutrients
so what's how does that what is that
matter today
um i think we have one of the greatest
biodiversity problems we have right now
is a
biodiversity of the human gut microbiome
we
the people in industrial north have this
really streamlined
biodiversity in their gut and that has
all kinds of health repercussions
and starts in childhood and it continues
into old age
so how do we what we've basically done
in
cities and in suburbs is and in
the conventional industrial farming
areas is engineered ourselves to the
very margins
of our environments and so gardening
puts people microbially back
into their environments and you can do
it in very tiny spaces we have these
we've got records of people producing
masses of food
six crops a year on a tenth of an acre
of land
um so i appreciate what ed is talking
about in terms of density and i don't
think it has to
annihilate the prospect of of
biodiversity
in fact if you look at american cities
most of our
a good portion let me say 30 sometimes
50 percent of our real estate is give us
devoted to cars
moving them and parking them and most of
those cars sit around
90 of the time those cities of the
future
can't have cars anymore i think the the
netherlands have just decided to ban
cars in their major cities
so what if we this doesn't take an act
of god it doesn't take
even an act of congress but just a
municipal ordinance shift
to vote that's that that territory
that's been given over to parking
devoted to plants
uh every new apartment has to have a a
gardening plot rather than a parking lot
and i think we could have a whole new
world
i agree with you and i'm curious we
hopefully in our discussion we can talk
about
um while that is certainly an appealing
vision of
of what our future could look like what
are the real challenges that stand in
the way
in terms of implementing that vision
which actually brings me to rory and
and rory um you know we've heard that
you know urbanization and sustainable
development biodiversity do not have to
be in conflict with one another
in fact they can support one another um
and yet as sunil mentioned
cities often play an ambivalent role in
in the project of development and in
fact
if anything maybe there's an
anti-urbanism
lens that many take so what was your
experience
um working within diffid now the fcdo in
the uk
in terms of what this looked like
in an international aid agenda so um
let me first preface by saying i'm going
to start with the focus on the uk aid
agency but it's worth looking at
differed because
it was one of the most thoughtful
progressive aid agencies and to some
extent
the way that different looked at the
world is characteristic of the way that
many people in the world bank and other
bilateral agencies look to the world
the first thing to understand is that at
the core
of the work of uh diffid and many of
these bilateral agencies is the idea of
focusing
on the very poorest people in the world
in particular the idea of focusing on
people who are living on under two
dollars a day
and that means that so much of the
programming
is about trying to reach those
individuals
that has meant for example a real
fashion for cash transfers an idea of
giving
um cash to families in order to
transform their lives either in a
monthly payment or a one-term payment to
help them set up
a micro business um following on from
that will be large programs
particularly around primary education
and primary health care
and a lot of the energy of the agencies
is absorbed in that kind of work
what isn't done by these agencies
traditionally
are very expensive large infrastructure
projects that's become less and less
fashionable
right there are other ways of funding
that some of that from the private
sector some of that from
development banks but by and large the
idea has been to take
the emphasis off dams roads
and on to the question of how you work
with very poor people
now fast forward what is the problem
then
that we confront the problem effectively
is that that
model right of working with very poorest
people
basically in people's minds in somewhere
like tanzania
has a rural feeling right the the
general impression is that you're
turning up in a remote rural area
where people have very little access to
services and you're worrying about how
to set up
a primary health clinic or a primary
school and how to work particularly
on for example agricultural extension
development work making sure that people
in those communities can
get more crops out of a given amount of
land and maybe get some loans to enable
them to access fertilizers pesticides
etc
but in fact the reality of increasing
what's happening in summerlike tanzania
is people are moving to cities
so you turn up in a city and you find
that 85
youth unemployment you find an
incredible number of people in their
late teens and early twenties who
swarmed in
i said maybe swarmed is a bad word but
have come in and very large numbers from
rural areas
and are struggling to find any form of
job
and the city is expanding unbelievably
quickly i mean one of the
the the challenges in the developing
world is that
tickable when i was first in kabul in
uh 2001 one the total population of the
city was approximately 400
000 people right today the population of
kabul will be
up pushing probably four or five million
and that's happened in in 20 years and
when that happens everything changes
right the water vanishes because you
start tapping a water table which simply
doesn't have enough water to keep it
city that sounds good
there is no sewerage infrastructure
there's no proper pipe water
infrastructure
uh informal settlements are springing up
on every hillside
and often collapsing and landslides
there is no provision of public space
there's no green space there's no parks
nobody's really thinking about mass
transit it's obviously no underground
system going in there's no
so what does the development agency do
and they're the problem and i'll finish
on this there the problem comes
which is that the mindset of the
development agency is still very much
focused on the very poorest people in
villages
and thinking about how you can change
someone's life
with let us say forty fifty dollars a
year
suddenly you are in the environment of
kabul
or darath salaam where what is actually
needed is literally
billions of dollars worth of investment
in laying the basic infrastructure for a
functioning city
and making some very very difficult
decisions challenging property
developers who are building very
dangerous
uh unsafe unsound buildings thinking
about how you could
generate a sustainable urbanism thinking
about how you might protect some of the
historical heritage the city
thinking about how you create your green
spaces how you get people walking
and there there is an enormous problem
an enormous problem in mobilizing
sufficient resources to do this because
this stuff is
incredibly expensive i mean creating an
underground system
is an astonishingly expensive thing to
do in any city
and very difficult for people
psychologically to justify you're in a
very poor
country what are you doing spending
literally billions of dollars right
trying to set up one of these systems
and yet you have to do it if you don't
make that investment now
credibly difficult to retrofit
i mean almost impossible now in kabul to
work out how you actually put that
infrastructure in because
so much rapid development has happened
in the last 20 years that it's very
difficult to work out where the space is
to get the sewerage in the water let
alone an underground system or
system okay i'm going to finish on that
because i want this to be more of a
conversation than my lecturer but yeah
somewhere somewhere in the problem is
diffid will talk about urbanism but it
will find it very very difficult to make
the types of investments necessary to
really help their islam or kabul into
the future
thank you rory well that's exactly where
i'd love to begin i'd just love to bring
any of our panelists in
you know hearing this challenge from
rory that the mindset of development
agencies
is focused on the very poorest living in
villages
not some of the challenges uh in cities
uh any thoughts from any of you just
reactions to
why that is or whether that could change
and if it were to change
where lessons from history might be
valuable
i don't think that's a mistake at all so
i in terms of disclosure i need to need
to say that since we're talking about
diffid that i co-lead the international
growth centers uh cities program which
is diffid funded
so uh we certainly do have a deep
gratitude to to differ
um and i think that in terms of the flow
of funds at least given current
development budgets that's exactly right
on the other hand it is also appropriate
for entities like the igc
to do research as i do on infrastructure
in the developing world in particular
infrastructure developing world cities
and to try and help those countries
figure out how to make those
you know those systems functional i mean
for example uh
you know rory has pointed out the
unbelievable price of underground
subway systems there's an old joke that
50 years of transportation economics at
harvard can be boiled down to four words
uh bus good train bad uh and in fact bus
rapid transit particularly the
developing world is a vastly more cost
effective means of of working things
um that being said i think in a
post-covered world
there is a view that uh at least it's a
it's a view that i that i have that in
fact covet should be a wake-up call
that the wealthy world should actually
especially the united states
should massively increase its commitment
to developing world budgets
and that investment should be motivated
by primarily by concerns for global
public health
and i i don't think spending on roads is
obviously part of that
but spending on sewers might very well
be uh if you have the view
that you know currently having unhealthy
water systems leads to the proliferation
of superbugs that are antibiotic
resistant
and it is amazing that the work of my
colleague dr marcy allison at uh
at the kennedy school finds that in
hyderabad the number of women who
entered the hospital
simply because they were pregnant but
were then tested for antibiotic
resistant diseases the numbers of them
who had them in their in their guts was
just enormous
right so we are really sitting on a time
bomb here and investing in water could
be a way of
fixing that um so i think those forms of
investment make sense and
i think it is possible that you might
even want things that are
more of a quid pro quo which is you you
get the money exchange for
a serious monitoring devices that
actually look out for outbreaks of
disease or
for the same type of hygienic policies
that we had in the 19th century
that kept animals away from humans right
so part of the critical thing is
we want to sort of separate out nature
and humanity so that we don't have the
sort of
cross species uh zoonotic diseases
striking as we've you know currently the
whole world has been suffering from
any other reactions to that sunil or
kate
kate i see that you want to jump in yeah
i think i'd go in the other direction
uh top-down development
you know you all could tell me the
history as well as anyone it hasn't
really worked
what i'm talking about working-class
people coming up with their own
solutions so
again take these peripheral
neighborhoods of um
of urban america people didn't have
sewers they didn't have roads they
didn't have streets they didn't have
garbage pickup
and what did they do they took their own
night soil they took their kitchen
scraps they took the scraps from their
animals that they lived
closely with not huge feedlots where
animals were being fed antibiotics but
their own you know five ten animals
chickens and
a hog and they recycled those nutrients
they
broke the metabolic rift that was
impoverishing
both rural areas and countrysides
excuse me when rural areas are
impoverished people flood to cities
but as these new height you know when
the new sewer systems come in
where does that sewage go it goes into
the local water sources and creates
these algal blooms kills
fish another resource depleted another
um biodiversity gone um
you know in american cities right now we
don't have a lot of horse maneuvers we
have a lot of human maneuver
and farmers take that they you know
that's cooked at really high
um degrees and farmers use that
um we don't really what's called
biosolids we don't often recognize that
but we're
growing food in human feces right now
um that was a that's a device that was
created by working
urban farmers a century ago it's a good
idea
i think we need to stop using the
failed cities in the western world as a
model
as a standard for failures exported
elsewhere we've done that for 100 years
it's i think it's time to move on
and can i ask you um in terms of if
there is a model
so if the model is not uh these
failed cities um you know hong kong came
up earlier can we talk about what what
are the models to look toward
and can i can i just come in here i'd
love to sort of bring you this is a
fascinating panel
one of the challenges i've found is
within development
is that although people would
allocate research money um
to the sort of work that ed is doing
very well
is that this stuff is not mainstream in
most of the
people who worked in my department this
is a little bit
outside their area of expertise so very
basic questions
on whether they are you know very
fundamental you know are you a disciple
of jane jacobs do you believe that what
you need to do is create cities with
mixed use
or are you supporting uh the kind of
zoning
that you see in american cities are not
conversations that most
development professionals are very
comfortable engaging in and don't really
have a view on
and if they end up giving money to the
ministry of urban development
in afghanistan they don't have a very
strong opinion on whether they're going
to be guiding them
towards a more pedestrian-based
mixed-use approach or whether they're
going to be allowing them to develop
huge banks for affordable housing a long
way from the city centre so
and maybe ed do you want to come in on
that um or maybe this is the kate thing
and i don't know
i i can certainly say something it's you
know
i certainly have been a fan of jane
jacobs all my life and
uh certainly all my adult life and
it's you know being keenly aware of the
failures of top-down planning
i think is important but shouldn't make
you anti-sewer right those are very
different things and and you can
simultaneously
admire uh you know the use of
night soil by farmers in china goes back
1500 years
of sanitation being brought to chinese
cities by farmers coming in the middle
of the night and taking that out
nonetheless the sort of work on you know
how
the amazing mortality effects that clean
water had
in the 19th century and there's just no
way of doing that that isn't
in some sense top down it was done by
cities not by the federal government
and it was enormously expensive
america's cities and towns were spending
as much on clean water at the start of
the 20th century as the federal
government was spending
on everything except for the post office
in the army
and i think it's just really important
that we approach issues like
global public health with a ruthless
pragmatism
that eschews any particular ideological
focus
right and that means there are some
things that are really best done
by the community for the community in a
way that is bottom-up and
and creative and there are some things
in which you really do need to
expect to do massive amounts of
investment if we're going to
get rid of the risks of of uh of you
know global pandemic
um but i will also say just in terms of
what you're saying rory we are
you know the past 15 years have been
great ones for urban economics
and we have had a flowering of fantastic
young scholars who
mean that you know the next 10 years
we're gonna have a lot more to say
to uh whether or not it's to the world
bank or defend on this than than
15 years ago thanks ed i wanted to um
just piggyback on your point that um
you know some things are best done by
and for the community and others with
massive amounts of investment
i want to bring some audience questions
in here and i think we're starting to
get at this question but
one question coming in is um
building on what rory had to say is the
answer to push toward these large
expensive infrastructure projects should
this become the focus of organizations
like
diffid and we touched on this a little
bit and i think we have different views
on this panel which is great
you know kate was mentioning earlier
that this top-down framing hasn't
necessarily
been proven to work and and we need to
look for bottom-up solutions and
and ed was just talking about the need
for both approaches
um and just wanted to bring in this
audience question on
you know would the way forward be um for
for diffid and other agencies to focus
on large expensive infrastructure
projects or i suppose to reframe
what is the most helpful role that
development agencies could play
and i think each of you might have
different views on that question
do you want join me to start first i
mean i think the the the first
question really for any organization
is what is it actually good at and what
does it know i mean you can over
five or ten years change the cultural
organization but you have to begin by
getting a sense
of what it can do well and one of the
problems is that
particularly in in development agencies
is that we
are very driven by fashion so every five
or ten years we suddenly decide we ought
to be doing something else
uh in in diffid's case look obviously
there is a strong argument for
infrastructure but the truth matter is
that
we've spent 20 years not really doing
infrastructure we don't have people who
really know how to do dams and bridges
and sewerage projects it's not our
expertise we have people who
have specialized in governance who are
specialized
in healthcare and education specializing
cash transfer
to some extent if we're going to do that
one of the key things is to make sure
that you're working with the development
banks that really have the
emphasis there the other thing i'd say
given that we've referred a little bit
to biodiversity and the
title of this is it's very important to
understand that we haven't
fully internalized the arguments the
environmental movement against a lot of
what we've been doing in development
so it's remarkable that very very
progressive
development professionals are still
pushing for agricultural extension
programs which are horrifying to the
environmental movement
in terms of the types of pesticides and
fertilizers that they're suggesting and
the types of crops that they're finding
it's also true that there's a very very
odd
discussion going on between our energy
development people who are still pushing
to develop
heavy oil electricity generation plants
and
compared to our climate people
incredible tensions between
people in our organizations who want to
build dams and new irrigation systems
and
the environmental movement pointing out
that these things are often going to
lead to huge catastrophic issues so
it's interesting i find within these
organizations that there isn't
really a space for intellectual debate
where these things are resolved what you
actually have
is often two quite separate
specialized departments deeply
disagreeing with each other but rarely
actually having the opportunity to make
these arguments openly and calmly in
front of each other
great point and a big challenge this
kind of gets back to what we were
discussing earlier
when kate mentioned plants instead of
parking lots but in terms of how we
get there when you have people with
different interests pushing for one
thing or the other including
agricultural
extension as rory mentioned there are
real challenges in terms of
getting to that vision um for the more
positive role cities could play
um kate or sunil any reactions to what
rory just said and otherwise we'll bring
in some more questions in a moment go
ahead yeah
it seems like one of the biggest
obstacles
and excuse me sunilo it seems like one
of the biggest obstacles is that
so much of development work and so much
of the way we think of
of where economies should go is is how
do we
turn people into consumers
how do we get you know how do we sell
more things and how do we get people to
consume
rather than thinking of people as you
know what do we do with people who
produce
for themselves who don't really produce
for markets who aren't making
anyone a profit who recycle their
manure their feces their seeds their
soils who produce a good part of what
they eat
who build their own houses who walk and
bike places
what do we do with them i mean we you
know if
if we need people to be consuming to
produce
profits for other entities that's the
big
our our big obstacle is ideological
i think once we start and think about
mutual aid and cooperative societies
then we then we have another
whole realm a whole palette of solutions
to come upon
i like that quickly i'll just say when
rory said that that intellect
the space for intellectual debate is
lacking sometimes
um kate you just brought up a good point
that when you
um kind of shift your mindset it unlocks
new solutions and if we don't have these
kinds of conversations we don't even see
those
those potential solutions so go ahead
sunil i just wanted to pick up on what
uh
rory was saying and kate has also
touched on in terms of the kind of dis
disconnected thinking
um and to turn that back to your
question catherine about obstacles
and you know i think we need to
acknowledge
sometimes that the obstacles are very
serious ones um
the lancet most recent report estimates
that 1.6 million people in india died
because of air pollution last year
um and it seems to me that the specific
problem of air pollution in a country
like india just take that as an example
um is is almost sort of worst of both
worlds because you have
that as a a combined and conjoined
product of
a rural poverty including energy poverty
i mean a lot of this
is um a black carbon being being burned
domestically um it's it's about crop
burning but it's also about
completely unrestrained automobile use
um in india cities
and i wonder in which you know what kind
of prop
what kind of problem does air pollution
pose
for development i mean i think that
there are all sorts of ways in which if
we think about public health we're
thinking about cities we need to be
thinking about the air as well um and
and
it just seems to me a quintessential
example of of how
multiple agendas um might be pushing in
very different directions because you
know on the one hand
uh one of the arguments is that the
reason why a crop burning has has
increased significantly in india over
the last 20 years or so is because of
the green revolution
it's because of of the third annual crop
it's because of the ways in which
um you know the nature of the
agricultural system
has has been pushing in that way um on
the other hand there's this sort of
urban rural divide where you know you
have the politicians in delhi blaming
haryana and punjab for the air pollution
in delhi
which is only really one part of the uh
one part of the problem so again i
i this is just a call for more of these
kinds of conversations which point out
some of the
contradictions that i think are sort of
uh often leading these
uh negative outcomes rather than the
kinds of
synergies that both caden had in their
different ways been talking about
somewhat amazingly the anti-poverty
program and reaga actually appears to be
somewhat to blame for air pollution so
this is the work of patrick
bearer at at the world bank that this
very well-meaning program to raise wages
for ordinary indians
uh by raising the cost of
labor-intensive agriculture
shifted a move to capital intensive
agriculture that was actually worse for
the environment
i just wanted to follow up on rory's
comment and clearly i'm sort of the most
i seem to be the most pro-infrastructure
person on this on this panel
but even i am not particularly in favor
of diffid all of a sudden getting into
the world
bank circa 1955 kind of business the
thing that that diffid can bring
is the part of infrastructure that it
actually knows which is the governance
part i mean infrastructure is not just
about structures it's about
what are the institutions that you're
using to manage that infrastructure and
what are the incentives you're putting
into place
to get people to connect to that
infrastructure and that's that's a
ubiquitous problem in the developing
world that you'll build a water main and
you'll have a white elephant project
that people aren't connected to
this was exactly the same problem that
new york faced in the 1840s and 1850s
when it built the croton aqueduct and
thousands and thousands of poor new
yorkers didn't connect and continue to
die of cholera
in fact my great-great-great grandfather
died of color in 1849 in new york seven
years after the croton aqueduct opened
right you needed to have a policy in new
york's case which actually penalized
tenement owners who didn't connect to
the water system to actually close that
last mile problem
in some cases you want might want
subsidies instead but in any case
that is the business of you know diff it
is to think about things like that and
to figure out what are our reasonable
lessons that can be drawn
from the history both in the developing
world and in the developed world
thank you ed so we've heard these go
ahead and quickly
please i i mean on that i think also
there is a question around community
mobilization i mean an enormous amount
of what works in kabul and actually
getting people to connect to water
supply or connect to electricity or
connect to sewage
involved some very patient conversations
almost household by household and really
trying to understand
why it is people didn't want to connect
what they were worried about were they
worried about the fact they'd be caught
in some taxation net
was it the cost of the connection that
was putting them off
was there some uh you know dispute their
neighbor over land ownership
through which the pipe was moving um
that too is something that
um is is sort of counter-intuitive in a
way that
if infrastructure is often led by
engineers there are often people who
don't necessarily have an intuitive
feeling for how you work how's the house
in a poor area i mean i remember working
with a sewerage engineering
i in kabul who kept saying of you know
splendid
kind of german sewerage engineer who
kept saying in relation to almost
everything but this doesn't make sense
you know why won't they do this right
and sometimes getting soft skills to get
around this question of
but this doesn't make sense you know why
isn't this happening in the logical way
that i expect etc
yeah great point i i wanted to get your
take on
kind of circling back to what we
discussed earlier why this topic why
now so sunil mentioned air pollution
and um you know the health implications
of air pollution being increasingly
clear we also have
covet 19 serving as a wake-up call and
uh these interactions between human and
animals happening in ways they haven't
before um
so we've talked about some of the
challenges right these conversations not
happening
or um maybe some of these organizations
not
leaning into their skill sets for how
they could best address this problem
um or or sees this opportunity
do you have what's your sense of whether
you know
beyond this conversation we're having or
conversations that seem to happen kind
of
on the sidelines right not in the
mainstream um
in terms of ensuring that urbanization
and sustainable development are actually
um working in cooperation with one
another
is this an opportunity for real change
do you get a sense that we're at any
kind of turning point
there's any momentum here that there's
an opportunity um
or it's part of the problem that this is
going to remain on the sidelines not in
the mainstream
well one of the most google phrases in
2020 in russian was how do you plant
potatoes
and i think there has been this return
to you know people are stuck at home
people are returning to their immediate
environments
and starting to sort of delve in i think
we're
we now know that we can make changes at
a lightning speed on a global scale
in ways that we hadn't thought were
possible before when it comes to
a global public health situation as
sunil pointed out we
we have global public health crises
all the time that have to do with
poisoned environments
but those are slow public health
problems um
we really only seem to be good when it's
you know infectious disease is
is immediate it strikes person you know
you know one day and then the next day
there's a major difference in health
it's the slow sicknesses
that have to do with contaminants
congealing in lungs
contaminants you know going into flesh
and slowly creating cancers and tumors
autoimmune disorders
those are the problems that we have been
really bad about dealing with and
and that i would hope that the pandemic
would get us to focus on
and then i think we would maybe reorient
our priorities less to the emergency
situation
and more to the long slow you know slow
violence of
of environmental problems
great framing of why now is different um
and what we've learned in this moment
did others want to jump in on that
one thing i suppose that strikes me as
um is
in in thinking this through it's very
important to try to
put yourself in the mindset of somebody
working in the municipality
of the developing country and really try
to
think through what's going on so um
that could include for example at an
extreme level corruption
right many many people in municipality
are extremely poorly paid
many of the decisions that they're
making may be taking place in the
context then having multiple jobs
or being under pressure from property
developers um
finances you know even in summer like
london a lot of very very poor planning
decisions are made
because uh the mayor of london is short
of cash and wants to try to make money
from property developers illegally
right you know rates money business
rates money revenue money and will
therefore authorize
it's huge tower blocks in places where
nobody wants a tower block
and where they can see enormous amount
of problems but that's the way they make
money
um uh problems of the poverty of a
population
so many many things will get stuck
because it's very difficult to work out
whether you can generate an income
stream will people pay for their water
rates will people pay for their
electricity how do they do that
problems of different layers of
government so there will often be
clashes between this
sort of sub-district level and the
mayoralty and standoffs on who has legal
power to do what and finally problems of
ideology
you know you will have often somebody
may be very well meaning
they may well uh not be corrupt they may
be trying to do the right thing
but in afghanistan the mayor that i
worked with in 2003 had trained in east
germany
and his mindset was still very very much
influenced by the
his training in the 1970s and early
1980s in east germany
and in particular his idea of what it
meant to be modern and a lot of what he
was doing was uh
trying to resist any attempts for
foreigners to impose what he thought was
an old-fashioned
or um sort of uh
and by modern he meant you know a sort
of extraordinary
high east german modernity of the the
mid 1980s anyway there's just
some random thoughts but i think
locating it in the culture of the
municipality
and and and its mindsets is important
i think that's very important and i
appreciate that point i want to bring in
a question from
the chat that um ed generously answered
in the chat but for those who
um are joining us on online
not in the zoom i want to make sure to
elevate this point
so one of the questions coming in is
what are the mistakes or lessons learned
from past strategies
that inform future planning initiatives
and public investment i mean
great question because that's exactly
what we're trying to get at by bringing
historians and practitioners together
understanding
lessons from history to informed
practice and ed i wonder um
not to put you on the spot but do you
mind just expanding on your i think very
thoughtful response in the chat and then
we'll see if others want to jump in
sure i mean as as has already been
alluded to the
the the litany of development errors
is just enormous right we have we have
an enormous number of mistakes
i do not share the view that western
cities are
you know failures but it is certainly
true that there have been
a you know a massive number of mistakes
that have been made
if i was going to pull the sort of meta
error
uh it would be the failure to plan for
the needs of humanity
and a focus on structures as opposed to
people
when building ultimately cities are
flesh and blood
they are not made of concrete and steel
and ultimately when you allow engineers
or builders or economists to build for
the sake of building
rather than to build for the needs of
the real people in the city then you
screw up and i think in some sense
that's the way to think about sort of
some of the worst excesses of post-war
urban planning
that being said as we look around the
world today
there are sort of two variants of this
one of which is monumentalism and if you
want an extreme version of this you can
look at astana for example right
sort of building vast towers to glorify
uh
the monarch to glorify the ruler it's an
old practice in in
uh in human history uh i would say that
you know most of the time where you see
sort of large
capitals that they are guilty of it but
there's another sin which is
uh nimbyism which is opposition to any
any uh
any tall building whatsoever and you
know this is something which
um as much as i i deride east german uh
planning practices uh it is also true
that borrowing from yorkshire is not
particularly wise from mumbai either and
yet
uh the uk town and country planning act
was indeed the model for mumbai's uh
planning out of 1968 and consequently
mumbai has labored under a 1.25 floor
area
restriction which means the average
height of new buildings has to be one
and a quarter
which is massive it doesn't stop part of
the reason that was imposed was the hope
that that would
restrict urban growth in mumbai of
course it didn't it just led to a
dysfunctional city now as has been
frequently said
i yield to no one in my admiration for
the genius of
ordinary uh indian urbanites who figure
out amazing things to do in places like
dharavi
but they have often been failed by their
by their governments
which have often just made it too
difficult to actually
do the building to do the city shaping
that's needed to survive and that's
that's both of these errors are you know
the cilla and charybdis of sort of
you know urban urban growth out there
one of which is building for the sake of
building the second which is
not building because you have some ideal
of some you know
city that you imagine that that you know
can only exist if we restrict people
from adding density
thank you ed i'm glad we elevated that
question from the chat
um and i was eager to hear a more
expended answer from what you wrote in
the chat
i wanna unless anyone else wants to jump
in on that i want to bring in another
question from our audience which
um specifically narrows in on um
food systems when we talk about lessons
from history to informed practice i know
that's something
kate has has provided a few examples of
um but this person asks
you know in many low and middle income
countries one of the key ways in which
urbanization affects the environment is
through food because cities have to be
fed
urbanization often comes together with
rapid agricultural intensification
and the development of food transport
and trade putting pressure on the
environment we've heard some examples of
this
any insights on how aid can help feed
cities
sustainably great very specific question
um any any thoughts on that i'll see who
wants to jump in
perhaps rory or or kate oh do you mind
if i um
go for it kate well my sense is in this
whole discussion
is that you know you can fix this and
you can fix that and you can give 40
a year to someone but if you keep
producing
and bleeding poor people if economic
systems keep doing that there's always
going to be a development problem no
matter what infrastructure you put in
place
so i guess my pitch is for relocalizing
economies turning
large-scale production systems that make
corporations phenomenal profits that
usually go to
big cities in the west and in the north
and making small-scale productive
streams so
what do urban farmers do they produce
local diverse organic food on marginal
land with
short market chains and few post-harvest
losses they use few very few fossil
fuels to do that they don't
dump pesticides and herbicides on their
crops
they make affordable nutritious and
fresh food that's consumed
right there if you know 10 feet from
where it was produced
the only problem with that system is it
doesn't make
wall street or other markets you know
big entities money
but it does produce wealth and and
wellness
rory did you want to jump in yeah i mean
this this this this i mean i
i'm deeply sympathetic towards kate but
the i suppose
that the two issues that are normally
raised in the policy conversation are
anxieties around cost but generally
the idea is that modern industrial
farming techniques and scale
re result in cheaper food for consumers
the second thing is that oddly there is
now quite a strong
movement from part of the environmental
movement
against low-intensity organic farming so
george monbiot for example in britain
is a real oddly a real supporter of
highly intensive pseudo-industrial
agriculture because he thinks it's the
most efficient way of using limited land
and it frees up
the rest of the land for rewilding so
there are sort of two models there's the
model which i favor which is closer to
kate which is a more low-intensity
organic
land use um the alternative model
is that you sort of divide your country
up between kansas and alaska
you go for the kind of crazy industrial
agriculture in one place and then you
have these huge areas occupied by wolves
uh in another area and and it's odd that
actually the environmental movement
can't quite decide which of those two
models it wishes to pursue and
quite articulate advocates for
environmentalism like mobile favor
industrial agriculture
i i don't have any views on agriculture
but i do want to just point out the
similarity between the argument rory
just made
and part of the case for urban density
is that by bringing people more closely
together in cities
we leave more land alone for nature
right so you're in some sense you know
the mantra is if you love nature stay
away from it uh as indeed human beings
are very destructive species i like to
like to tell the story of henry david
thoreau burning up 400 acres of prime
woodland
as part of his you know enjoying melding
with nature nature thing
the same point is about sort of living
densely means less carbon emissions and
actually means being kinder to nature
and means leaving more
more land available for wild things
thank you ed so i'm gonna bring in one
more question and then we only have a
few minutes left here
um so i'll i'll bring up this question
for consideration but would love each of
you to close
with any key message you want this
audience to walk away with um so the
question is around
what came up earlier moving to bottom up
um
a bottom-up view of this connection
between urbanization and sustainable
development
and and the question is with many
governments now focusing on
infrastructure projects particularly in
the uk
are there good examples of bottom-up
funded infrastructure projects
um that we can look to so again just a
question on examples models
um so would would welcome any thoughts
on that but with just five minutes left
i'd love to just um go back to each of
you for
a quick point you want the audience to
walk away with
um a call to action maybe for how things
could be done differently given that
i think there is some opportunity here
for um
us to think differently and maybe act
differently on this topic
so we'll close with sunil um because he
helped to bring us together
but um i'll look to kate ed
rory see who wants to jump in first any
final thoughts and if you have a
particular example others should take a
look at
um as we leave our conversation today
there seems to be an interest in some
specific examples and models so
rory can we start with you yeah yeah so
so i i think that
the thing um that is important
is to understand how unresolved these
discoveries are
really important to understand within a
bureaucratic department that we don't
really explore
uh the fact we disagree um
and and there are suggestions of this
actually in this conversation i suspect
that if we had another
three four hours being cheeky ed and
kate don't agree on everything
um but often within a department those
disagreements are not fully brought to
the form there will be disagreements
which are empirical
right disagreements on what works
there'll be disagreements on priorities
you know so some people may be more
worried about the gut by them and
another person may be more worried about
income
expressed in cash terms but there will
also be
normative or moral disagreements to do
with your entire conception of values
which very very rarely play any role at
all
in discussions with environment agencies
and so i think this is quite useful and
i think if we can
acknowledge that although we share a lot
and we agree a lot we also
disagree uh and bringing out those
disagreements is an important part of
progress
and that will be my contribution thank
you i agree um
ed or kate who wants to jump in quickly
and
we do have to keep our remarks pretty
short here but um
can i go to uk and then we'll go to ed
sure
um well just in closing i think you know
these last remarks i
i think we need to point out that the
history of environmentalism
itself is is a little dark
and very much an elitist agenda
that we just saw sketched out um you you
know
have dense urban cities super that
leaves you
all of alaska free for wildlife who gets
to go to alaska
only the elite who can afford those
expensive trips to alaska and everybody
else is
in their concrete jungle um i think we
need to rethink
environmentalists and and think of it a
new kind of working-class
environmentalism where people have on
the ground made
really sort of brilliant new
technologies and advances and
innovations that
have been missed in plain sight that's
that's just all i'm trying to point out
thank you kate ed will go to you sure i
i i just have have really
three points and i'll be and i'll be
fast one of which is where i started
which is that this pandemic reminds us
that we are all of us on this planet
in this together and in fact if that
does not
renew the commitment of the wealthy
countries of the west
towards investing in and learning from
and
being part of a development process
together then it is an
opportunity terribly missed the second
point is
there is no escaping our urban future
right it is there and even if you don't
like it and i very much do like it i
think that
is you know the best chance we have for
cultural political change as well as
prosperity as well as a
world of of hope rather than a world of
fear it is there
and we need to approach it with a
ruthless pragmatism as i have said
earlier
that is not ideological and very much
focused on
solutions that improve the lives of
ordinary urbanites uh throughout the
planet
and the third point i want to make is
that yes
we absolutely do want bottom-up uh
things as often as possible
but you know you you're not going to
crowd source a
coveted 19 vaccine right it's something
that's going to be produced with cutting
edge technology and we need
that too and so we must not forget
in our desire to like ground up things
and i very much do believe in the jane
jacobs vision of neighborhoods taking
responsibility for their own
that we also sometimes need governments
that work
right and in some sense what we are
seeing around us in most of the world
with the covet 19
uh pandemic is a massive public failure
and
that cannot we cannot respond to that by
saying we just are going to
look for bottom up innovation we need to
actually get our governments to be more
functional as well
thank you ed sunil will go to you i
think um we have different visions
of of what uh what to do in this moment
of time but
agreement that it's a moment of
opportunity and so can you just
um give any final thoughts on on
again as we started why this topic why
now and what's the way forward
i think one thing i've learned from this
conversation this wonderful conversation
is that the visions matter i mean i'm
thinking about rory's east german
trained engineer i think our
visions of of human flourishing at this
moment
need to be made explicit and need to be
put into conversation with one another
and and the sort of conflicts within
that i think
you know upfront and recognized i think
this is a moment of opportunity but i
think it's also a moment of
um of alarm because i think you know i'm
struck by what kate was saying earlier
we've made quite clear we can respond to
a pandemic but
there are um crises that kill many many
more people than covert 19 has so far
terrible though it has been
uh about which there's been total total
inaction and i i would like to see a
sort of pivot towards thinking about
some of those
quieter less immediate crises which have
to do with the relationship between
environment and human health and human
well-being thanks sunil well this is one
of those conversations i wish we could
continue but we are out of time so i
just want to thank
our panelists for their time and
expertise and thank our attendees for
your
time and attention and great questions
this is definitely one of those topics
that benefits from
bringing historians and practitioners
together and it was a pleasure to
moderate so thank you all
and we'll see you in the next edition of
the yell development dialogues